hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to baldies basics
kickstarter field trip now this is a
demo for the Kickstarter that is going
to make an official baldies basics and
educational learning game god I love the
inputs of this song here so this is uh
apparently more of a proof of concept
but we're going on a field trip which is
always fun but I must survive while also
trying to score as high as possible the
better your score the better your
rewards the highest scores will even get
you permanent buffs that lasts for the
rest of your game which I'm assuming is
gonna end as soon as I die which is
gonna be a lot maybe any description of
this is probably gonna pale in
comparison to the actual games oh oh I'm
sorry
my curiosity often gets the better of me
and I apologize for that so there's
nothing else yeah oh I don't like that
um something doesn't feel right about
what I'm seeing right there so I'm just
go spit adil over here and see if
there's something else were okay well is
it oh no seriously that's it stop
there's nothing else
so there's you you'll regret this I
don't think I will
no breaking the fourth wall on the halls
I'm sorry what are you gonna do about it
okay alright then well I'm just gonna
back away slowly
oh it's one-way walls of text wait is
the same thing behind the other one too
or is there anything behind the other
one I'm sorry I'm trying to explore
anything oh okay okay oh I hate your
mouth I don't often say that to someone
as soon as I meet them but I hate your
mouth so is that weed on the ground what
is that a nice ball sack of a cloud over
there okay well you know how about oh
how about we don't oh um teacher I don't
think I'm supposed to be oh oh
oh ho hum I uh I didn't mean to do this
teach if you could believe me
all right thinking the fourth wall in
the hall I didn't mean it look I didn't
mean it
I just got curious you never been
curious in the fourth wall in the halls
okay can I come oh ah
oh you silly [ __ ] uh-huh
oh my androgen meter is still there much
teeny tiny err but it's still there okay
all right I'm gonna move on then that's
all right you know what you make a
compelling argument Baldy hey this
reminds me of a doom mod oddly enough a
really terrifying doom mod oh I got a
stick I got one two three sticks I don't
like the sound of whatever that is Wow
indeed I live to please mr. bald man
what is that that a bear trap
should I not touch that or should I am I
absolutely touch that ouch my Dingle
donger okay there we go
with that stick go cuz I got it and I'ma
bring a stick back that was the
objective that was given to me
okay got stick I got sick teach oh
that's a pleasant sound hmm
well if the only danger in here is
sticks and bear traps I think I'm gonna
be okay
well better skedaddle heed Adil back
here so what am I
Wow Wow I know right pretty impressive
teach huh I'm a pretty cool happenin
student and did you have to set so many
bear traps you know I just wanted to
might have run that by you the idea that
maybe there's a bit too much bear trap
here maybe I really don't like the way
the crickets know how close I am to
death oh I'm real slow now oh it's heavy
carrying Styx's oh oh I don't have any
Sprint's oh that's not good yeah good
her in time oh I know that was a lot of
points those it sure was a lot what
happens when I run out come on go I only
got so much time left but I guess that's
good though I mean would Baldy be mad at
me if I if I didn't keep fargo oh I know
right Baldy nothing sticks whoa hey Wow
time you won is where you'd get some
great rewards based on your
[Music]
huh let's go again
okay I'm just I'm listening to you teach
I'm gonna go eat some candy and do some
drugs out in the woods you can't stop me
I'm a rebel you can't stop me I'm just
kind of seeing what's at the edge of the
world over here I got two sticks you
know I'm gonna do with two sticks all
right so I can't go off the map here
it's gotta be something in this woods
right oh hey whoa teach whoa Bobby hey
whoa hey come on now hey Walt Baldy
but Baldy Baldy Baldy wait whoa was that
was that necessary was in it was that
necessary who's a necessary what if I
get him to walk into a bear trap huh
what if I do that huh what have you hit
a bear trap huh stupid idiot huh baldies
[ __ ] come here you didn't the bear
didn't there's no bird you didn't get in
the bear trap well I'm real slow teach I
got six tricks I got six sticks teacher
I got into six cuz of your math that
helped me learn how to count and then
I'm on a go adventuring on the woods you
see this will give me more time Wow I
know teach I know I'm pretty goddamn
impressive got a big ol throbbing brain
that's able to think of stuff and also
math I'm able to think of math I'm not
able to do math but I'm able to think of
it real hard
well maybe if I throw sticks at him oh I
just dropped my sticks my sticks my
sticks I'm ruined
well my sticks baldie please let's talk
about this hang on wait baby Baldy baby
Bob
oh that's closer than I thought you'd be
okay I think that's it I don't think
that there's anything else here I mean I
could try to go out as far as I can here
and see what's in the depths of Hell in
the infinite sky box that is this zone I
guess I'm doing that because what better
do I have to do with my time sorry
yeah Peyronie's still going woody do do
all right oh no I'm still going I
thought I hit a wall there all right au
revoir
Irv wha Baldy [ __ ] I'm gonna well I'm
going I don't know where that bus was
going but I'm heading to the woods on
foot you you take the bus I'll walk
we'll see you beets they're through
there and we'll see who beats who there
oh and it just faded away I'm now lost
in the void I would never be able to
find my way back all right with nothing
else to do I guess I'm just gonna go for
the high score yeah Baldy I'm going for
it gotta get back I'm gonna get a new
record mm-hmm okay don't don't die yet
I've got a seven I got eight sticks and
a lot of sprint will be sprints good a
band oh I know Baldy
you're pretty goddamn impressed from
wherever the hell you are in the woods
let me tell you something else that's
impressive about me my kung fu my huge
dick and then my my my
nothing nothing I got nothing else
impressive besides those features oh
there's no sticks left there's no sticks
I got all the easy sticks ah oh oh it
was not a full go it was not a full go
was it Oh
10 seconds I got to go I got a bucket
baby give me Derby's Oh God shitty tikki
sticks not where hey whoa hey Wow
hi mazhab time was up
oh damn you are I'm gonna get those
sticks fire going so I can roast your
corpse over it when I get back hmm last
be Baldy the cannibal if I'm even human
I've got load of sticks a big bundle of
sticks that's seven not as many as I
would like oh and I'm out of sprint whoo
aah I'm not get ball deed maybe it was
more risky than I have zoomed oh wait
wait I didn't know that's how you did
that why did you were you in the fire
the whole time dad that just raises more
questions about why and how and what you
were doing in the fire I'm gonna have
nine sticks maybe if I can get okay is
it gonna be a close one hope I don't see
the devil getting summoned I've got nine
sticks there's got to be some kind of a
record oh wow pretty good right guys
pretty good I know right
Wow one stack one of you get so many
sticks in there if the bugs just start
chirping at a higher and higher
exponentially higher frequency so they
eventually all explode in the woods just
engulfed in flames so close don't kill
me
all right Wow indeed
yeah I'm pretty good yeah yeah I'm
pretty good I would get some cool roids
okay so that is the baldies basics
kickstarter field trip demo if you guys
want to play that for yourself try to
beat my high score of 51,000 but right
now the developer of all these basics is
trying to raise money to develop a full
version of the game I don't know what a
full version of the game is gonna be
like but I imagine it's going to be a
kind of encompassing all aspects of
school in terms of education and
learning so we're the first baldies
basically probably just about math the
other ones would have geography field
trips recess all this good stuff but
then again I don't know check out the
Kickstarter I'll provide a link in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching it and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye-bye